I became Prime Minister almost three
years ago
immediately after the British people
voted to leave the European Union my aim
was and is to deliver brexit and help
our country move beyond the division of
the referendum and into a better future
a country that works for everyone where
everyone has the chance to get on in
life
and to go as far as their own talent and
hard work can take them that is a goal
that I believe can still unite our
country a new delivering brexit was not
going to be simple or straightforward
the result in 2016 was decisive but it
was close
the challenge of taking brexit from the
simplicity of the choice on the ballot
paper to the complexity of resetting the
country's relationship with 27 of its
nearest neighbors was always going to be
huge while it has proved even harder
than I anticipated I continue to believe
that the best way to make a success of
brexit is to negotiate a good exit deal
with the EU as the basis of a new deep
and special partnership for the future
that was my pitch to be leader of the
Conservative Party and Prime Minister
that is what I set out in my Lancaster
House speech and that was what my
party's election manifesto said in 2017
that is in essence what the Labour
Party's election manifesto stated to and
over 80% of the electorate backed
parties which stood to deliver brexit by
leaving with a deal we've worked hard to
deliver that but we have not yet managed
it I've tried everything I possibly can
to find a way through it's true that
initially I wanted to achieve this
predominantly on the back of
conservative and DUP votes in our
parliamentary system that is simply how
you normally get things done I thought
the changes MPs demanded I offered to
give up the job I loved earlier than I
would like and on 29th of March the day
we were meant to leave the EU
if just 30 MPs had voted differently we
would have passed the withdrawal
agreement and we would be leaving the EU
but it was not enough so I took the
difficult decision to try to reach a
cross-party deal on brexit many MPs on
both sides were unsettled by this but I
believe it was the right thing to do we
engaged in six weeks of serious talks
with the opposition offering to
compromise but in the end those talks
were not enough for labour to reach an
agreement with us but I do not think
that means we should give up the House
of Commons voted to trigger article 50
and the majority of MPs say they want to
deliver the result of the referendum so
I think we need to help them find a way
and I believe there is now one last
chance to do that I've listened to
concerns from across the political
spectrum I've done all I can to address
them and today I'm making a serious
offer to MPs across Parliament a new
brexit deal as part of that deal I will
continue to make the case for the
Conservative Party to be united behind a
policy that can deliver brexit nine out
of ten Conservative MPs have already
given the withdrawal agreement their
backing and I want to reach out to every
single one of my colleagues to make the
very best offer I can to them we came
together around an amendment from sir
Graham Brady and this gave rise to the
work on alternative arrangements to the
backstop although it's not possible for
those to replace the backstop in the
withdrawal agreement we can start the
work now to ensure they are a viable
alternative so as part of the new brexit
deal we will place the government under
a legal obligation to seek to conclude
alternative arrangements by December
2020 so that we can avoid any need for
the backstop coming into force i've also
listened to unionist concerns about the
backstop so the new brexit deal goes
further to address these it will commit
that should the backstop come into force
the government will ensure that Great
Britain will stay aligned with Northern
Ireland we will prohibit the proposal
that have
future government could split Northern
Ireland off from the UK's customs
territory and we will deliver on
commitments to Northern Ireland in the
December 2017 joint report in full we
will implement paragraph 50 of the joint
report in law the Northern Ireland
Assembly and executive will have to give
their consent on a cross community basis
for new regulations which are added to
the backstop and we will work with our
confidence and supply partners on how
these commitments should be entrenched
in law this new brexit deal contains
significant further changes to protect
the economic and constitutional
integrity of the United Kingdom and
deliver brexit it is a bespoke solution
that answers the unique concerns of all
parts of the community in Northern
Ireland but the reality is that after
three attempts to secure parliamentary
agreement we will not leave the European
Union unless we have a deal that can
command cross pop wider cross-party
support and that is why I sat down with
the opposition I've been serious about
listening to views across the house
throughout this process that's why when
two Labour MPs Lisa Nandi and Gareth
Snell put forward their proposals to
give Parliament a bigger say in the next
phase of the negotiations I listen to
them so the new brexit deal will set out
in law that the House of Commons will
approve the UK's objectives for the
negotiations on our future relationship
with the EU and they will approve the
treaties governing that relationship
before the government signs them and
while the talks with the opposition did
not reach a comprehensive agreement we
did make significant progress in a
number of areas like on workers rights
I'm absolutely committed to the UK
continuing to lead the way on this issue
but I understand people want guarantees
and I'm happy to give them so the new
brexit deal will offer new safeguards to
ensure these standards are always met we
will introduce a new workers rights bill
to ensure UK workers enjoy rights that
are every bit as good as
or better than those provided for by EU
rules and we will discuss further
amendments with trade unions and
businesses the new brexit deal will also
guarantee there will be no change in the
level of Environmental Protection when
we leave the EU and we will establish a
new independent Office of Environmental
Protection to uphold the highest
environmental standards and enforce
compliance the new brexit deal will also
place a legal duty on the government to
seek as close to frictionless trade with
the EU in goods as possible subject to
being outside the single market and
ending freedom of movement in order to
deliver this the UK will maintain common
rules with the EU for goods and
agri-food products that are relevant
checks at the border this will be
particularly important for our
manufacturing firms and trade unions
protecting thousands of jobs that depend
on just-in-time supply chains the most
difficult area is the question of
customs at the heart of delivering
brexit lies a tension between the
strength of our ambition to seize the
new opportunities that brexit presents
and the need to protect the jobs and
prosperity that are built on an
interconnected relationship with other
European economies this ambition should
not be divisive there are many people
who voted to leave who also want to
retain close trading links with Europe
just as there are many people like
myself who voted to remain and yet are
excited by the new opportunities that
brexit presents indeed I believe one of
the great opportunities of leaving the
European Union is the ability to have an
independent trade policy and to benefit
from the new jobs and industries that
can result from deepening our trade ties
with partners across every continent of
the world but I've never believed that
this should come at the expense of the
jobs and livelihoods that are sustained
by our existing trade with the EU and to
protect these both the government and
the opposition agree that we must have
as close as possible to frictionless
trade
the UK EU border now the government has
already put a proposal which delivers
the benefits of a customs union but with
the ability for the UK to determine its
own trade and development policy labor
are both sceptical of our ability to
negotiate that and don't believe an
independent trade policy is in the
national interest they would prefer a
comprehensive customs union where the UK
say entrer EU trade policy but with the
EU negotiating on our behalf if we're
going to pass the withdrawal agreement
bill and to deliver brexit we must
resolve this difference as part of the
cross party discussions the government
offered a compromise option of a
temporary customs union on goods only
including the UK say in relevant EU
trade policy and an ability to change
the arrangement so a future government
could move it in its preferred direction
we were not able to agree this as part
of our cross party talks so it is right
that Parliament should have the
opportunity to resolve this during the
passage of the bill and decide between
the government's proposal and a
compromise option and so the government
will commit in law to let Parliament
decide this issue and to reflect the
outcome of this process in legislation
i've also listened carefully to those
who've been arguing for a second
referendum i've made my own view on this
a clear on many time many times i do not
believe this is a route that we should
take because i think we should be
implementing the result of the first
referendum not asking the british people
to vote in a second one but i recognise
the genuine and sincere strength of
feeling across the house on this
important issue the government will
therefore include in the withdrawal
agreement bill at introduction a
requirement to vote on whether to hold a
second referendum and this must take
place before the withdrawal agreement
can be ratified and if the House of
Commons were to vote for a referendum it
would be requiring the government to
make provisions for such a referendum
including legislation if it wanted to
ratify the withdrawal agreement so to
those MPs who want a second referendum
to come
the deal you need a deal and therefore
withdrawal agreement bill to make it
happen so let it have its second reading
and then make your case to Parliament
finally we cannot expect MPs to vote on
the same two documents they previously
rejected so we will seek changes to the
political declaration to reflect this
new deal so our new brexit deal makes a
10-point offer to everyone in Parliament
who wants to deliver the result of the
referendum one the government will seek
to conclude alternative arrangements to
replace the backstop by December 2020 so
that it never needs to be used to a
commitment that should the backstop come
into force the government will ensure
that Great Britain will stay aligned
with Northern Ireland 3 the negotiating
objectives and final treaties for our
future relationship with the EU will
have to be approved by MPs for a new
workers rights bill that guarantees
workers rights will be no less
favourable than in the EU 5 there will
be no change in the level of
environmental protection when we leave
the EU 6 the UK will seek as close to
frictionless trade in goods with the EU
as possible while outside the single
market and ending free movement 7 will
keep up-to-date with EU rules for goods
and agri-food products that are relevant
to checks at the border protecting the
thousands of jobs that depend on
just-in-time supply chains 8 the
government will bring forward a customs
compromise for MPS to decide on to break
the deadlock 9 there will be a vote for
MPs on whether the deal should be
subject to a referendum and 10 there
will be a legal duty to secure changes
to the political declaration to reflect
this new deal all of these commitments
will be guaranteed in law so they will
endure at least for this Parliament the
revised deal will deliver on the result
of the referendum and only by voting for
withdrawal agreement bill at second
reading can MPs provide the vehicle
Parliament needs to determine how we
leave the EU
so if MPs vote against the second
reading of this bill they are voting
just
brexit if they do so the consequences
could hardly be greater reject this deal
and leaving the EU with a negotiated
deal anytime soon we'll be dead in the
water and what would we do then some
suggest leaving without a deal but
whatever you think of that outcome
Parliament has been clear it will do all
it can to stop it
if not No Deal then it would have to be
a general election or a second
referendum that could lead to revocation
and no brexit at all who believes that a
general election at this moment when we
still not yet delivered on what people
instructed us to do is in the national
interest I do not and my views on second
referendum are well known look at what
this debate is doing to our politics
extending it for months more perhaps
indefinitely risked opening the door to
a nightmare future of permanently
polarized politics look around the world
and consider the health of Liberal
Democrat democratic politics and look
across the United Kingdom and consider
the impact of failing to deliver on the
clear instruction of the British people
in a lawful referendum we do not have to
take that path instead we can deliver
brexit all the changes I've set out
today have the simple aim of building
support in Parliament to do that I
believe that is a majority to be won for
a brexit deal in the House of Commons
and by passing a deal we can actually
get brexit done and move our country
forward if we can do so I passionately
believe that we can seize the
opportunities that I know lie ahead the
world is changing fast our young people
will enjoy enjoy opportunities in the
future that my generation could never
have dreamed of this is a great time to
be alive a great future awaits the
United Kingdom and we have all we need
as a nation to make a success of the
2020s the 2030s but we will not do so as
long as our politics remain stuck in an
endless debate on brexit we all have to
take some responsibility for the fact
that we're in this an pass and we all
have as
ability to do what we can to get out of
it the biggest problem with Britain
today is its politics and we can fix
that with the right brexit deal we can
end this corrosive debate we can get out
of the EU political structures the
Parliament the Commission the Council of
Ministers that are remote from our lives
and put our own Parliament back in
sovereign control of our destiny we can
stop British laws being enforced by
European Court and instead make our own
Supreme Court genuinely supreme we can
end free movement and design an
immigration system based around skills
that work for our economy and society we
can stop making vast annual payments to
the EU budget and incident stared spend
our own money our own priorities like
the NHS we can get out of the Common
Fisheries Policy in the Common
Agricultural Policy design our own
systems around our own needs and
resources we can do all of these things
and by leaving with a deal we can do so
much more besides by reaching an
agreement with our EU trading partners
we can keep tariff barriers down and
goods flowing friction-free across
borders protecting jobs and setting our
firms up for future success we can
guarantee workers rights and
environmental protections with a deal we
can keep our close security partnerships
and keep working together to keep people
safe we can ensure that the challenge of
the land border between Northern Ireland
and Ireland is met in a way that works
for people on both sides this is a huge
opportunity for the United Kingdom out
of the EU out of ever closer Union free
to do things differently and doing so in
a way that protects jobs protects our
security maintains a close relationship
with our friends and works for the whole
United Kingdom it is practical it is
responsible it is deliverable and right
now it is slipping away from us we risk
losing a great opportunity this deal is
not the final word on our
future relationship with the EU it is a
stepping stone to reach that future a
future where the people of the UK
determine the road ahead for the country
we all love this Dior lays the
groundwork and settles many of the core
issues but in the years ahead
Parliament will be able to debate decide
and refine the exact nature of our
relationship with the EU some will want
us to draw closer others will want to
become more distant both sides can make
their case in the months and years ahead
the key thing is decisions will be made
not by MEP Zoar commissioners or the EU
Council but by the United Kingdom
Parliament elected by the British people
that is what being an independent nation
state is all about those debates those
decisions are for the future what
matters now is honouring the result of
the referendum and seizing the
opportunity that is right before us so
we are making a new offer to find common
ground in Parliament that is now the
only way to deliver brexit over the next
two weeks the government will be making
the case for this deal in Parliament in
the media and in the country on what is
best and right for our country now and
in the future and on what the majority
of British people of all political
persuasions want to see happen tomorrow
I'll make a statement to the House of
Commons and there will be opportunities
throughout the bill for MPs on all sides
to have their say but I say with
conviction to every MP of every party I
have compromised now I ask you to
compromise - we've been given a clear
instruction by the people we are
supposed to represent so help me find a
way to honor that instruction move our
country and our politics forward and
build the better future that all of us
want to see thank you